the Joe Rogan experience and they did it
people are mad in Hawaii over that movie
Milano which is my favorite movie
ten times well some of them were mad the
activist sort when they said is Wyatt no
I know no he's uh he's uh he's Pacific
Islander okay but anyway but I'm up in
Hawaii right I can't remember the
believe he did oh well whatever he's
[ __ ] gorgeous and since Jason
Minnelli [ __ ] Momoa yeah god damn it
anyway so every I guess I'm real
that is pulchritude yeah that's male
pulchritude right there some cheesecake
add beefsteak and pulchritude it's like
whoa would you let me see them Barenaked
have you been paying attention to the
controversy about building that new
telescope in Hawaii
oh of course I prayed against it did you
it came to me you know this is something
that shouldn't be told so I'll tell it
and I said don't worry about it sis I'm
putting in the Jew the Jew two cents on
this here you don't want them to build
the telescope well not on the people's
holy place so I went out there and I
done some prayers for direction and it
stopped
three days later and now it's back on
but all the people went up there but I
like to say to the people I'm glad you
got the telescope I say this never hates
me it's okay but I just have to say
maybe maybe the telescope which will be
the new eye to behold the entire
universe which will create like such a
different kind of a human mind forever
maybe that should be there I don't know
well um in terms of where it sits in the
world well it's where Pele is right
that's where Pele was born and the
Hawaiian people they say they believe
that they came out of that mountain you
know and that that's their Jets that's
their uh what do you call their their
Genesis mm-hmm is that particular Mauna
Kea mother mountain
so they don't want anything built on
that maybe there's some sort of a
compromise because the the idea that
place is that it's in a very unique
place on earth do you view the cosmos
have you been to the Keck Observatory
I've never gone there because I you know
I should it's amazing it's amazing the
view up there my grandkid changes your
your your place like your idea of your
place in the world the first time I saw
it
we're so visual beings yes that you know
what changed me are those round think
the round films about the Wall of China
it meant in those uh whatever those
places are those theaters IMAX
yeah oh I'm talking about yeah those
gigantic theaters where everything's
around you yeah you get to see it
visually
yeah well the Keck I I've been doing a
few times but one time I caught it
perfectly where there was no moon out
and the sky was clear and it was
unbelievably beautiful you see the whole
Milky Way see all the stars the entire
skies filled with stars it didn't even
seem real and it just makes you feel
like you're looking through the
windshield of a spaceship flying well
there's this app you can get to that
will chart the stars for you and it's so
cool and if you hold your phone up which
I felt my pool and you hold it and that
you hold it up there and look and it's
like yeah yeah there's this yeah you
know yeah I can't remember I had a
similar app maybe it's the same there's
the spot constellation yeah yeah yeah
yeah no it's incredible it is incredible
there's not there's nothing like seeing
yet all of that pales when it comes to
me thinking about me funny it's so
incredible that's one of the things that
helps people think about their place in
the world when you see something as
magnificent and enormous as the Milky
Way and I do like all that you see the
Milky Way so clear that it doesn't even
look real I've always caught it like
that once the other two times that I
went to see everything the other two
times that I went it was still beautiful
but not as stunning as the one time work
hard at one time I messed up and I got
there was a full moon it was a mess you
couldn't hardly see anything when the
other time was really cloudy it was hard
to see but the one time I saw it was
just oh to this day I think back on it
it blows me away because it
it really shifted you know in a real
tangible way the way I viewed people on
a planet in space it just it's
undeniable because it's so gorgeous and
so epic centering your eye and expanding
your whole mind yeah and that does
something to your big ass program DNA
[ __ ] you know once the eye sees it and
takes it in it's like the image once the
image is digested you know the image you
know they say where does it stop being
that and become this Ryan you know oh
that integration that's the word
integration yeah in the mind I think
that lack of ability to see that is one
of the things that's really screwed us
up more than anything about modern
civilization with all our lights our
street lights and city lights you can't
see the sky anymore when there's no
lights at all then you see all the stars
and then you realize like oh we're in
space or in space like this is just the
nighttime I'm not just in Manhattan
looking at the sky know that we're in
space when you have a full blackout in a
place like Manhattan and also you look
at this guy like what is going on all
these stars have been here the whole
time
but you could never see him light
pollution it's a terrible I never heard
of light pollution is a terrible thing
that we've done we've denied people the
view of the most gorgeous thing and all
of the universe the universe itself
there's no thing they put up those
lights to help the homeless so you know
they don't get raped and murdered that's
a that's what San Francisco did serve
let San Francisco did to help the
homeless well
[Applause]